what a predictable turn from Nancy
Pelosi today well she and her caucus of
course have spent the better part of two
years claiming that Donald Trump and
Putin are basically spooning together
President Trump obviously seemed
frightened in the presence of Putin what
was he afraid of what is Putin
blackmailing President Truman Trump with
the only leader who he is totally true
to is Putin I've seen plenty of evidence
of collusion you don't need to be a
lawyer you don't need to have access to
classified information from an
intelligence perspective we need to make
sure that the president the United
States is putting America first not
Russia
oh well as Glenn Greenwald the
intercepts said today in a tweet if
Trump is literally controlled by Putin
to the point where Trump is forced to
act in the best interest of Russia at
the expense of the US which has been the
prevailing claim not of dem fringes but
it's mainstream how can it be morally
justified not to impeach him well Nancy
oh well today Pelosi said in a new
interview no to impeachment adding he's
not worth it
no wait a second is Nancy talking about
Trump there or Muller because now it
looks like the special counsel may come
up empty on this collusion deal so Nancy
just wants to move on from that to just
plain old regular demonizing Trump 24/7
one of course Pelosi and company will
get plenty of help from their state-run
media outlets all the way through
election 2020 he has more than 10,000
lives racked up already but don't forget
he said it in two days or he'll live
lies and obstruction of justice final
show progeny racism white nationalism
Saul Alinsky would be very proud kids
but the ruthless demonization doesn't
stop with our current political
leadership because what the left wants
is a total transformation of our country
the remaking of our history enter stage
left their new socialist poster child
who's not only claiming that FDR's New
Deal was racist but that Ronald Reagan
was
is to I think a perfect example of how
special interests and the powerful have
pitted white working-class Americans
against brown and black working-class
Americans is Reaganism in the 80s when
he started talking about welfare queens
he's painting this like really resentful
vision of essentially black women who
were doing nothing that were sucks on
our country and to think I didn't know
that the word sucks could be used as a
noun hmm learn something new every day
when to think that they actually lined
up around the block to hear that searing
intellect well with such gratuitous
meaness about one of the most beloved
presidents in the past 50 years the
South by Southwest festival should be
renamed I don't know the mouth and mouth
worst festival and as we've documented
here in the angle week after week month
after month there is a concerted
across-the-board effort in the Democrat
Party to demonize the entire American
experience in the American tradition by
degrading anyone in anything that
doesn't pass their own radical Mustard
now remember the it kids at the moment
they can be the leaders of tomorrow god
help us so it's important that we not
merely dismiss these episodes in fact
anyone interested in preserving our
freedom in our free market not to
mention the historical record must use
these moments to teach a new generation
the truth about the country we love our
triumphs and the tragedies that we
should learn from but in the vicious
landscape of the social media world
untruths become truths if they go on
corrected I have a question do we even
really have speech in America today if
millions of you feel afraid to speak
your mind for fear of being demonized at
work at school at your universities even
in the military on the left the impulse
today is to control speech not encourage
more of it
CNN president Jeff Zucker was also at
that South by Southwest festival
justifying the DNC's decision to deny
Fox a chance to host a Democrat debate
he basically said no one has the right
to you know get a debate and then he
went on to say well let's keep scrolling
guys they said well look Fox is
basically state-run TV so they don't
have an obligation to give unto Fox it's
you know it's I think the question
should be is Fox state-run TV or blah
blah blah well rejoinder question has
CNN become resistance TV where the
president and by association a huge
swath of Americans who voted for him are
treated like evil Neanderthals what the
president is proposing here does not
sound like it's in keeping with American
tradition when it comes to immigration
the Statute of Liberty says give me your
tired your poor your huddled masses
yearning to breathe free
president Trump is poisoning the
American people it is getting worse
every day the President of the United
States is racist all of us already knew
that this make America great again hat
is just as maddening and frustrating and
triggering for me to look at as a KKK
hood this is CNN well where does James
Earl Jones go to get his voiceover back
after that thing isn't anyone to the
CNN's facing a 250 million dollar
lawsuit for defaming the reputations of
those Covington Catholic students the
network routinely allows its ideology to
eclipse facts and then the demonization
game soon begins a few weeks ago CNN
actually hired Sara isgo Flores she's a
Harvard Law grad and a former Jeff
session spokeswoman at the Department of
Justice she was hired it was surprising
to me as a CNN political editor I mean
what was CNN thinking hiring a
conservative well the announcement set
off shockwaves through leftist circles
liberal journalists went bananas started
writing pieces maligning her so my
question is did she lack any more
journalistic experience than these
people you can see them on the screen
who were granted Network perches after
their political stance
no yet the DNC was quick to register its
displeasure with is scre in the role of
political editor at that network a
Democratic Democratic campaign committee
aide told The Daily Beast Chairman Tom
Perez and the DNC Express to CNN that
they have serious concerns with the hire
they continue to talk to the network
about how this impacts 2020 and as of
Wednesday they got assurances that esker
would not be involved in debates not
only that Jeff Zucker demoted esker to a
mere political contributor Will shall
have zero role in shaping the coverage
of the Democrats or their debates well
the good news is no one's watching CNN
so doesn't really matter
so we'll I've got a question that will
some crack liberal journal on tedious
magazine piece about how CNN is the
mouthpiece with a direct line and the
DNC and vice versa now don't hold your
breath but it's important to note the
tactic here the left is committed to
distorting history and destroying the
past while demonizing anyone and
everyone who stands up for American
values and traditions what started as
the removal of historical monuments has
now become a full-on assault on
presidential legacies and the movements
namely the conservative movement that
was created and by the way for
conservative does manage to secure a
post inside one of these old dinosaur
bastions he or she will be vilified
condemned without cause and driven out
because the fanatical left
well it's no longer about winning in the
arena of ideas for them it's no longer a
debate and may the best person win no no
no no instead they just work to take
players off the field with blindside
hits everybody
but just not that funny if Democrats
want to make a difference I have a
suggestion why not start engaging
instead of demonizing your welcome on
this show anytime
how's that for openness meanwhile
Democrats don't really have any defense
do they for what's happening let's say
on the border nor they gonna try to
convince voters that then do a better
job at living leveling the playing field
with China and forcing fairness and
trade or maybe how they'd raise your
standard of living or have a stronger
economy than trumps you know why they're
gonna not make that argument because
they can't all they really have left is
some iteration of your racist if you
don't agree with us that's not woke
that's just a sad joke and that's the
angle